like we live in so it was really funny
we're live in five four three two
blast-off okay hey do you have the
comments up as well on your thing or is
it just me no how do I do that
you don't have to if you don't want see
but um I mean so I'm streaming on both
twitch and YouTube yeah I'll just get
out my phone because oh look it came off
my phone just just thinking like so you
can get involved in there the comment
section as well because last time I was
like saying random things you had no
idea what the comments section was
actually saying yeah oh I could see you
well I shouldn't I shouldn't be looking
at this oh yeah don't cheat though just
I'm gonna cover you with a bit of papers
I think you get up YouTube on the PC you
can just slide it over to the other
screen and then um yeah wait and you can
pop out the trap as well oh yeah wait I
do have two monitors here let me just
get the other monitor up I don't think
he ever uses this one let me just go hey
motoki hey Montez hey Nikki hey Esteban
Miranda who watched the last that's my
bad hello hi sorry I left for a minute
I'm just trying to get mr. Devon a syrup
I couldn't get all the lovely comments
I just hit myself in the eye with the
tomato have you done some reason the
sound has changed to the peat hi Jackson
everyone say hello Jack Sam in the
comments hello Jackson j ax om I don't
know I'm sorry everyone I'm having some
technical difficulties I've got my IT
guy on it all righty guys
mm-hmm thanks I live in IT guy you know
in voice you it's fine I'll just I was
just fired pizza or something buy him
some flowers I could do I don't think he
likes flowers though what's the male
equivalent to like flowers he doesn't
drink so much I can't buy a beer there's
no games that are cheap enough to just
know exactly just like wanna me get on a
win yeah say hi he said hi I've had to
toss you and you like laughing it's
really funny okay let's continue with
the game
yeah hmm so for those who missed last
week basically tick tock is a co-op game
but it's a puzzle game and Amy sees one
part of the puzzle and I'll see the
other part of the puzzle and then we've
got to kind of explain to each other
what we can see
in our view of the game so that we can
progress throughout the game and we play
together unfortunately though we don't
play the same instance of the game which
means that we can't do things that
directly influence the other person
screen which would be so cool if that
was the case but it's still fun it still
it still you know it's still working I
can't believe what we're doing I
remember being very angry when we left
and I was like we sort of ran through
all the puzzles got angry at them
because we were hungry and they were
like other players they go yeah so I'm
back in the house again here with the
phone oh I'm at the gates where's the
house oh yeah because we can yeah
because we can't get in the gates come
because there must be like um yeah a way
like a some certain way to do the lights
or something yeah well I think so we'd
we did this phone and there's numbers
corresponding to the bits that we read
and I think the numbers are important
somehow oh yeah
so yeah you had all the beginnings and I
had all the endings we know give me
another tick tock is an app so many
people like you play me up here I feel
like we should once just okay my man
Todd oh yeah cuz he's gonna play this
hey Felipe its young man and Amy by the
way you want to say hi to Amy hi
hey hey how you doing okay so I'm back
at the phone yes same so are we gonna
try and figure out like in what order is
that what we were trying to do yes so
you had the first ice number two it
starts with hey Luke I'm so glad you
finally Hey oh here I'm so glad you
finally decided to pick up the phone
I've been leaving so seven and they
write this down too and then seven yeah
sorry what did you say I've been leaving
yeah I've been leaving earlier but you
did dot never mind only still only still
or are you still sorry yeah are you
still there
you know your raven that went missing
the one you named Cole I made a new one
for you I'm going oh sorry did I tell
you that the name of Noah - seven seven
three three and then mine was a little
squiggle oh okay like a - but a squiggly
one even have my random ones up yeah me
too ever they've got certain ones let me
unclip oh yeah right so yours us about
the raphe oh you know your raven that
went missing the one I think thinks the
one wait yeah I think it is the one yeah
you named Cole I made a new one for you
so that's zero zero
okay I made a new one for you oh it's
upstairs and it's even better this one
cannot die that's yes the one that
cannot die so that's eight yeah
is that like . or yeah . so yeah number
one and my star in my hash as well I've
still got a plus sign six five and nine
okay so get up the ones that you haven't
used yet okay maybe it's a separate
combo yeah or just like another sentence
okay what's one of your starters do you
have like a yeah I've just got so I'll
tell you mine so number one is was
pouring down and made me scared no idea
I'm guessing that's about rain yeah must
be do you have anything about rain on
your land
no I've got one that says to visit there
is now a dark tower but nothing about
rain okay so I've got number four that's
note that before I left I made you
something to keep which seems to go with
the original conversation I just don't
know where yeah well I've got one that
might fit it says angry comma but don't
hang up on me yet I really want you to
know that before I left I made you
something to keep okay that makes sense
mmm okay angry and made me scared mmm
okay so um oh I've got the one before
that but it's not the start of a
sentence okay what does it say it's the
star and it says you so or asterisks of
wherever the hell use so many messages
exclamation mark wait
exclamation mark I know you're still
I agree but don't hang up on me yet yeah
yeah okay that works
Oh my other two was just like bits of
sentences like nine says you company
comma I would have told you there was
mad at me when I arrived and that's the
end of the sentence and those that makes
sense to me mm-hmm
we bad at this maybe I don't know I've
got a hash it just says can no it's not
the same but please just go see for know
number one makes no sense as well the
pouring down it's like that must be
about right maybe they just throw it in
there to like continue this yeah maybe
well we've got a sequence two seven
three squiggle zero eight oh wait maybe
it's a maybe it's a some maybe we should
put I feel like if we put a good
sequence in this phone something will
happen
oh you think yeah I don't know just
saying things well what's the sequence
again 273 so mine would be 2 3 yeah and
then you'll last 1 0 yeah total just add
this phone there's no way we can make
the other ones work I don't think so
should we leave the phone yeah okay
we've been done I don't know probably
I'm going into the oh the trumpet shop
place or I've got those dials remember
um so you've got dials and then I've got
Morse code just weird mosque oh you've
got the be pbbb pbbb but I cannot make
it
hmm cuz mine's like the one you had and
I told you like North West and stuff
yeah I tell you anything but maybe I can
put in the beeps like with our thing I
don't know - oh okay so - seven I don't
know what is Morse code though is it
like three beats per line or like how
does it work exactly it's the alphabet
and dots and dashes I know but all I can
do is dots and then I can hold it you
can hold it - two - will do that's all I
can do oh because we've put 273 - right
yeah I can just do Dodson and dashes
and I don't really know what I'm making
you've got nothing about Morse code in
your end it just makes no sense no I
just got those dial things I can press
buttons but that's just a lock I've got
44 46 and 48 and that's it
should we go in the next place okay
I used to scroll down the clocks place
no no no okay so the really this is the
darkroom and you can scroll down oh my
god I remember this this is me I was
like what makes no sense
but I've just noticed you know on the
machine at the top I have to like dials
yeah so maybe that will help us with the
other place maybe Oh so Milanovic just
gave us SOS in Morse code so maybe I
could try that if this doesn't work but
yeah yeah I'm someone a Novick thank you
bro right yeah what is it
it changes every time it changes every
single time it changes so maybe they
just ask you what you're no because it
wouldn't no game wouldn't no it's not
it's not on the same server doesn't know
so yeah so like I'll do micro and then
I'll do a snake and then right now it
says too but I don't know like where I'm
counting from
so like I've tried to go like - from the
snake but like which way I know I'm
right to figure out what the numbers
could be meaning but I'm just gonna do
all of them and see what works but my
number keeps changing so I don't think
it's the same every time but our games
aren't leaks there must be no oh yeah it
must be the same every time
yes yours is waiting for me to figure
out what one you should put in right but
then why is my number different every
time
what does I only see one two or three no
it will say like eight four two one like
random numbers the next one's a moth and
then I got I've got one number five and
math all the butterflies it says five oh
you got a number
yeah I got a number that time so I did
crows snake and then the moss butterfly
whatever we're calling number five how
is that number five hmm Nelson number
eight but I still press them off and it
still works yeah
[Music]
yeah wheat oh this is so sad it's not
the girl and it's not the world at that
time but how do you know if it's at the
seventh position like it depends on
which way you're counting like left or
right and where are you start you know
yeah I'm not having any luck actually
maybe try counting from the top left
corner it's just there my mouth was top
left corner and that was number one
apparently okay right mmm maybe the
numbers are like two keypad oh oh no
that doesn't make sense
it's a good call though is it so
Milanovic but yeah but number five had
and the five would be the unlock button
oh there oh wait so Milanovic is saying
maybe it's like one two three four five
six of em I thought he meant like a No
num keypad it could be let's try that
seven eight nine four five six
oh okay actually just work thank you or
something like a fake I don't know
let me just do for that one
what was yours what's your number five
and it's the keypad the keyhole Koki
it's next one make minus one so that's
one snake minus 1 1 1 D 1 was another
quick high up but fake one it wasn't
snake it was one it was one just it told
me that snake minus one but that means
one but I clicked one onion some moss
and it didn't work
oh okay well it was a time Turner hiring
out Hermione Granger oh okay right um
right this snake hey scan that didn't
work for me what the toy snake snake no
no no right crow snake moth keyholes Oh
time gone backwards
oh maybe uh maybe it wasn't no to the
cortex I just realized it would have
been a different place anyway so that
was okay wait
so wait keyhole cog I know kids not look
hug it's not the COG yeah it's the whole
time the COG and then something right
[Music]
their mother and their mitres puppet
it is the time Turner and then what the
car and then the [ __ ] then the lover and
the ladder and then it said the puppet
so I click the girl but I don't know if
that works I think pop it okay great and
now it is the Mafia is it yes and
there's more wait wait wait we need to
do it together we need to do it together
well I'm too late girls ok wait I'll
wait for you happy moss a lot of +2
I need to wear green okay should we go
again together hello wait I'm wearing
green why cuz it's Saint Patrick's Day I
thought it was yesterday
no that was the night that everyone
drank yes part for me because I'm an old
woman and I drink all day instead I've
got a nail I have a coffee
ok now I'm in green me too
are you yeah I'm wearing like a okay
green shirt like a t-shirt by accident
purely accident officer Naru Serato st.
Patrick's Day cupcake cute hmm okay
ah right let's do this together this
time okay teamwork okay right when do we
keep on three three the lag wait we're
doing it on or one mana or on go go
after one wait I'd six it okay okay
snaky hometowner
call COG and then right away the trim
the girl the girl then the moss then no
the time - no it's not
wait oh sorry plus three yeah no you're
right okay let's do it again right three
oh wait okay three two one go was after
the month again keen you hold to your
antenna
it's long oh yeah railway railway puppet
puppet girl hope it girls I'm on
five-plus so that's all again month
again mine turned off sorry okay three
two one go
[Music]
the key no time to [ __ ] we need all
right I need to do this together because
you said puppet I click puppet and
obviously I was behind you
Wow let's do this together okay okay I'm
going
one two three good right together
Craven snakes no moss no keyhole
[Music]
now walk come reload the railway line
now outfit the puppet ok no muss again
boss for I got for a snake snake well
Wolf Wolf Wolf
ok feather what does that mean bad bad
snake snake like nine and then diagonal
Oh the keyhole ok cog cook slither snake
ah oh my dog but that works better but
we're doing it together you know step by
step together so let's not run ahead
ok ok ok
we were two away Thule was so close ok
right ok
3 2 2 1 go ok
crap fried snake mama keyhole
time-turner with a bloody hell they are
now okay
papa now what was it [ __ ] but mark again
mas wolf plus one snake my no Wolf Wolf
bailed of birds Raven Raven know what
snake snake o bird plus to the keyhole
key now Carla [ __ ] yeah
snake Nick yes okay well you take time
The Crow the second to last one is
definitely chrome second bite okay
because they've all go to crow and then
I'll have the last one yeah okay right
oh my god bye Billy three two they said
hi no I said hi hi Billy
[Laughter]
okay
it's the birdie bird thanks well now
it's them off key hold here time Turner
now it's the time Turner and the COG
[Music]
girl what is this the mom come on okay
another snake snake now uh yeah well
- its Raven Raven know what it's a good
sneaky snake
it's a keyhole key huh
no now it's the ladder the railways I
don't think you know it's [ __ ] oh
sorry it's the COG look at there we'll
get there okay I need to take off this
jump for thy just pause it's too hot
sorry I will Green for a little bit
count okay
this game is killing me three two one go
good okay
bird pawns snake mama keyhole called
railway no way girl girl now uh mom mas
steak oh my god that well thanks what
that Walczak well Bart birdie bird bird
uh snake no five a keyhole ah okay um
and now it's the cold right now it's a
snake oh my god okay now it's bad it's
the bird it's going to be the Lassa it
must be the ladder escape not o ski home
was it the keyholder i think so right
away by a train like an escape tree it
looks like a lot of to me yes when I
named you press buttons what the hours
quality content
oh my god
okay yeah babe huh it's like I was
looking for dog O's how did I end up
here where you got two [ __ ] I should
put the drink down no teasing I told you
I'm a lightweight nowadays yeah she's
gone are we gonna do this it's wild
okay yes three she likes to be some
motivational music I can sort this out
for us wait what motivational music yes
like eye of the tiger or something like
oh my god yes oh wait no will get
demonetized oh well it's not copyright
free motivation you gotta find something
no copyright free motivational
background music royalty free uplifting
and inspirational music and chanting
inspirational music royalty free
apparently this is enchanting can you
hear it they can sit here okay
right I feel like we should do this this
is our one chance to put right the
mistakes that we have made in the past
because what is life but learning from
these mistakes the escapes the mistakes
that we make don't weep why do you make
a mistake when you're telling your
sentence it's okay because the ones who
know you they don't need you to explain
verbally they can see what you mean
through your eyes and now it's your
chance so do what is right and press
those [ __ ] buttons I can't wait to
one no okay okay okay crash sink hey ma
ma Keith Hall Tina Turner hi my girl
ah it's their mom mas stay snakes snakes
make it departs snake snake snake snake
key hole key girl now it's the snake and
now what I did it wrong
the birds so now the keyhole oh I did it
I did it oh my god I did it you might
have but I still need to do it I did it
by myself
even how do I do it now
oh yeah I just remember it and be fine
okay okay okay micro snake lake moss
keyhole right sure
yeah Hancock okay railways is a girl
yeah girl yeah
keyhole no it wasn't it wasn't it was a
month what do i do do I have to turn ice
and do it again
crow we should have done it together so
snake muffles
kifo time tuna calc Hulk no we're way
then the girl no no call that an early
mark oh yeah mend them off then what
then the sacred thing snoop oh yeah well
let's make again
no it wasn't keyhole no wait leve time
went off it's just showing me northwest
how could you leave me behind
wait I'll just write down what it says
here because it's just showing me
nothing
hey Justin Equis why are we still here
just a super and this love she did it
without you I'm left behind
ohana means family nobody gets left
behind
oops I mean the video back
yeah because o mine doesn't work now
yeah I know it won't work because I need
to finish it - yeah can you like go back
to your main menu and like no you can't
oh [ __ ] this is the floor in the game
design not only I was just getting
confident oh damn it
no no but like because this game is not
run on the same server it just implies
like that we are working at the same
speed but we might not ok I just turned
it on it's fine I just turned it on
again okay
get here I don't like it tell me what
it's time I turned it off okay you ready
three two one again mas mas mas eat the
snake wolf
well now the bird bird know what snake
another keyhole oh it went up oh I think
it was just that was the code sorry
okay Brad I'm getting bored of this I
want to get pads right right three - the
snake Wolf Wolf Birds okay no snake key
holes
key cog cog snake snake and the bird
bird apart then the keyhole oh my gosh
thank [ __ ] christ for that right I've
said so and then southies Oh what is
your thing
mine just has two crosses on Northeast
so you think it's north east south wait
what's your outside circle saying
I don't have an outside circle I've just
got two compasses two separate ones
oh okay so you've got south and
themselves
Maui's yeah so should I go back and try
back oh wait you're looking sorry you're
looking at the screen I was looking at
above yes and they're both on the
outside circle and they they just yeah
oneself and one southeast because you've
got a replicated version of it on your
compasses at the top right yeah my both
just say stuffies I mean northeast oh
okay my like the top of mine is blocked
off I can't see them oh okay so what
does your first cog say now
so that's North East in the south and
then the second one's southeast yeah
okay so we go back to the place and try
it then okay yeah yeah I guess the part
of us oh my god hey the lights are on
you're like the radio yeah I think it
said snow
should I go back to the place no no
let's be this while we're here might as
well okay who starts okay you start
because I've got doctor dots before mine
three patients from the nursing home in
Hill Beck have vanished in the middle of
the night
the talent is only revin has returned
from Switzerland she is determined to
reopen and bring back glory to Ravens
cogs the police are looking for anyone
who was in the unity of the nursing home
yesterday evening they are asking for
assistance finding the missing patients
the post offices water damage is
repaired and all post boxes are ready to
be used again there is already a letter
in post box 34 that means I need to do
this isuh for the tragic nursing home
incident has reopened old wounds in our
village we hope these disappearances
won't remain unsolved
like those five years ago you have no
news when train service will return to
our village again the station is now
permanently closed
hence the gates klarisa sharra the
generous benefactor of our new clock
tower died last month at the opening
ceremony next week we will honor her
memory
well she was she could Claire Clarissa
so sure there is no wait I think yea
Clarissa
mmm-hmm creepy okay okay 34 it said
right yeah we can always go back and
double-check if not I don't have any 34
I've got 44 46 and 48 now well maybe it
was a different one wait wait wait I had
loads so maybe you can scroll up or down
Oh what in Oh
oh yeah okay yeah right so my proposed
means e that one yours okay opened like
scanner sorry it says post office
telegram it feels like I was gone for
such a long time but for all the time I
was away it still felt short too short
to finish my invention now we will have
the longest lives ever longer than you
could imagine
and you've repeated this message I'll
guide your way when you've repeated this
message I'll guide you what that makes
no sense
it says 1997 when you've repeated this
message what yeah it feels like I was
known for such a long time all the time
I was away it still felt short too short
to finish my invention now we will have
the longest buyers ever longer than you
could imagine when you've repeated this
message I'll guide you obey repeated
okay that's interesting like I use this
a writer
again like huh there's one that's open
now that I've scrolled up there's like
one that's open right at the top but
there's nothing in it that it's 16 the
one that's open and this was 34 so how
did you open it I used the the North
like the from the buttons that I used
that I just on those two just on 34
the other one was open already okay cuz
you had it was two different
combinations right like the southeast
yeah cuz I was full as full arm so put
two North East one myself and want to
South East and so is that to do with the
the Morse code like well it opens the 34
way it did do something it opened there
yeah yeah but what like what do we do
now
like so anything in the box has anything
to do with Morse code or should I use it
on all of them no no like in that one
there must have been something specific
to happen in there instead of just just
a letter was that all that's it that's
not post office 90 nights and then it
says six five eight nine zero really
really faintly six five eight nine zero
maybe maybe we should try the phone
again put six five eight nine zero oh
that's a good idea
okay see that mmm six five eight nine
zero you said yeah that or your numbers
apart from zero oh I just really a buzz
yeah okay doesn't make sense
mad at me when I arrived I agree but
don't hope not for me yet I really want
you to know it doesn't make sense no
yeah you should try the moss no what do
I do with it like I don't know what to
do but it would make sense that the
letter has something to do with the
Morse code because we're both in the
same building the one with the trumpet
on it right yeah yeah so I'm here and
all I've got is the Morse code maker but
I don't really understand how Morse code
works with numbers or anything so I'm
just Google will do you know I don't
like cuz it it's meant for words right
it's not meant for numbers so I didn't
really understand just anyone in the
chart understand walls coach read me the
letter again please yeah and there's
also so many different types of Morse
code and I'm only I'm only able to do
two different things a dots and a dash
like a middle - it feels like I was gone
for such a long time but for all the
time I was away it still felt short too
short to finish my invention now we will
have the longest lives ever longer than
you could imagine when you've repeated
this message I'll guide away
how could we repeat the message is
obviously something in that that we have
to do
yeah say it again sorry nice it feels
like I was gone for that she longed but
for all the time I was you cut out then
oh it feels like I was gone for such a
long time but for all the time I was
away it felt short too short to finish
my invention now we will have the
longest lives ever longer than you could
imagine
when you've repeated this message I'll
guide your way I feel like I repeated it
so how should you pay my way and there
was nothing else in there
no just says post-office telegram I'm
just putting those yeah through Nicky
listen are there are there any dots and
dashes no no it says she just a
paragraph okay so what were the numbers
again cuz Simon Arabic is giving us
numbers in Moscow um six five eight nine
zero six is - and four dots
I know what five which is looks like
it's five dots that's it that's all I
had room for wait how much room do you
have that was it enough for that
so go ahead you've got ten ten
whatever's yeah dashes and dot's hmm and
then it goes wait maybe you should put
in mmm
repeat just the word repeat it was
repeat right that she said repeat this
teaches when you've repeated this
message what else is there there must be
something else to do there's the
lightbulbs I feel like we're not there
yet was the lightbulbs yeah well we we
need to know the pattern for the light
bulbs yeah
[Music]
hmm this means so much harder than I
know the last one was pretty easy right
like yeah we let Bruce ooh gross breeze
through like - um I'm just gonna put the
same coordinates in all of the other
ones to see if anything else happens cuz
click-and-drag I think yeah
yes oh that was in postbox 34 right yeah
and the other post foxes that was open
with 16 and there was nothing in them no
it's empty like someone's taken
something out of it
there wasn't any like hidden bits of
paper in the other rooms or anything was
sold
it's tough okay
I'm gonna pop to the toilet okay you
have a little look around
have fun
yeah I can read the chat go back to the
phone where's the phone
I'm back hey someone on the back Amy can
read the track yeah except that's the
phone Chuck see Jack she's peeing in the
corner of the room how did you know I'm
so stuck office iteration this is why I
like racing or shooting game okay yeah
they said go back to the phone it's just
like I was thinking while I was on the
toilet
hi as you do you wouldn't design a game
expecting your player to know Morse code
because who uses that anymore you know I
mean like if they would give you dawn
dashes to work from hundred percent yeah
I know it's a puzzle game but I just
like I wouldn't necessarily expect the
player to know it's just doesn't make
any sense so I just expect some sort of
dot and dash system to be somewhere like
on one of those letters but you said
there was none so it just it was
literally just words yeah say nothing no
no the words were like underlined no
nothing was like it was just paragraph
Gassman how are you so outgoing huh what
where did you get this from
okay nice and light on it super dark
sorry I left for a sec what did you say
nothing okay
I just want to see if I could like move
around the I come back to the phone and
I've got a little thing that we put in
there
it was 273 sweetly - 0-8 but I don't
know I'm stuck
yeah we both have to use the phones at
the same time but this 273
you understand I feel like we're missing
something with the phone because there's
five places where you can put numbers
and I feel like we both need to put in
numbers and then click the phone and
something else is gonna happen but I
feel like we're both missing something
maybe the sentence that we created is
than what we think it is maybe
[Music]
absolutely you're pretty outgoing I
don't know how you can get that from a
light stream are you talking about
I know that you're not going jump
earlier duh that's crazy
uh maybe the text in the most then he
hits a little busy taking phone it's
maybe we can't call 911 once I've got
the line and she's on it's nine nine
nine nine yeah I need you know nici's
the number ones right I have it's not
helping
yeah we've already tried to make this
story from the sentences we've got yeah
because I wasn't right so maybe we
should try making another story I guess
I'm the only one that has a starting
sentence though hey lark I'm so glad you
finally maybe I've got one starting
sentence because I've got there with a
question mark and then you know your
raven that went missing the one and that
was the one that we've already used that
can't be the start of a conversation cuz
that doesn't make any sense
well I mean maybe it's not me you me you
me you like maybe it's me me you me you
you know I mean I maybe let me go back
and forth like that
yeah maybe um I'll see if I've got
anything else that could go along from
this hey lek I'm so glad you finally and
then I have like weird ones like you so
many messages you named call
I don't glad you finally know that
before I left I made you something to
beep know you told you I'm so glad you
finally know it's gotta be you because
none of these wouldn't make any sense
so you you've gotta have two seconds
second line to that what was it again
hey Luke I'm so glad you finally decided
to pick up the phone I've been leaving
I've been leaving okay I've got
something different okay asterisk right
use so many messages this actually makes
more sense Ashley I've been leaving you
so many messages wait I know you're
still and then you could do your angry
one what's my angry one remember you had
one that's not a bit angry so what was
your sentence really one was fun for me
you so many messages wait I know you're
still angry but don't hang up on me yet
I really want you to okay let me write
these ones down so what number was your
first one two again okay so my mine was
seven and then your second on the
asterisk asterisk and mine is five so it
says angry but don't hang up on me yet I
really want you to I already want you to
know I miss that way there okay right so
to answer
before no yeah
I really want you to know that before I
left I made you something to keep and
made you keep something to keep I made
you something to keep yeah is that like
full stop no oh you company I would have
told you keep you company
okay okay wait what number was yours for
four mine was nine I would have told you
she have anything that matches up with
that so I'm looking at the chat okay I
was looking at start see I'm writing
them all down
well here sits - seven asterisks five
four nine okay
four nine so sorry what was your
licenses again you company I would have
told you I would have told
[Music]
I've told you I've got one that might
fit I've got I would have told you in
the my next to visit there is now a dark
tower does that make sense there's any
of yours too asterisk Oh was it for yeah
he's doing you're so you're too and then
I'm seven yours is asterisk that I'm
five and then you're Ford I'm nine I
would have told you already I but you
never mind
I still maybe I don't know what was that
one I'm gonna tell you earlier but you
desert never mind
are you still are you still there yeah
yeah okay so what number was yours but
what did you think you're you're swirl I
thought mine was to visit there is now a
dark tower just cuz you said you didn't
have anything to go with it number three
number three a three and mind is the -
so you there you know your raven that
went missing the one you named calm so
that must be zero
you named call i made a new one for you
it's upstairs and it's even better this
one cannot die okay maybe hopefully this
will be it so you press the sheer
present I'll wait I haven't okay let me
see so mines ever five nine asterisk
eight okay if you got yours
yes Wow okay what do you the mechanical
crow the one that will last forever
yeah oh wait did you see that I'm
actively you can see what I can see can
you see that yeah I've got mechanical
in a cage and then there's like oh god
said said I don't the Crone I've got
drawings of the crow so it's like how
they made the grave so you've just got
drawings I've got a mechanical crow in a
cage and at the bottom there's three
like spaces and there was said said said
in it but I can change them too like
yeah different letters of the alphabet I
reckon is probably a lot of stuff can
you do a lot of different things of this
crow or I've got loads of different
letters of the alphabet in these three
Bob the alphabet in the box yeah but
I've got like an O with a cross in there
and then the AE that's joined up
together I've got an A with a dot on top
of it like a weird said what do you do
with it well I think you should have
something for me to put in it and all
those drawings do you see any letters or
anything yeah there's loads of like
numbers and letters but it's more just
like this Cobb is number a and then this
side is number six like well I don't
know what you want from me
I need letters only three letters okay
a X we're just a normal a not with any
weird dots or anything no thanks grab an
ax then what like as if I think this is
a fall with an L maybe I can't
Abey Abey Abey Abey Abey XC maybe that's
where the birds head b XC nothing do you
have does your owl look like a one like
just a line down no
I've gone i cuz it's like so I've got
loads of drawings of random cog parts so
I've got cod cog parts but I've also got
something that looks like a clock it's
got 12 3 6 9 and then loads of little
balls in between and on the left hand
side it looks oh it looks like the oh
it's cords the Morse code thing and on
the right hand side it's the mechanical
parts head
so this must be oh well I thought I was
going to tell us how to do the Morse
code yeah cuz I just got a cage with the
mechanical bird in it and then three
boxes at the bottom that I can put asses
in so you've got Morse code stuff so
maybe that's you well I don't have
anything that tells me how to do the
Morse code I've just got this like clock
and on the left hand side from 6 to 12
on left so like it's like inside the
clock is a drawing on the left hand side
of a Morse code tapper and on the right
hand side is the mechanical bird head
right there's a [ __ ] have any like
what's the clock set to because maybe
that could help no hands it's just the
bird head and the Morse code image
inside the clock on the left hand side
is the moss hand code on the right hand
side Reds head and then I've got so I've
got some cogs and it's telling me that
they should be going in clockwise motion
basically and then I've got some
mechanical parts and it's just basically
telling me that a is 6 centimeters in
diameter and yeah it's telling me like
of them or I've got the bird's wing
which has a cog inside the wing and I'm
not by it for some reason it says figure
nine and four centimetres I think that
says don't know if that means anything
to you
and then I have the bird's head and it's
telling me that it's like I think that's
one centimetre up top by the beak and
then there's another mechanical device
that's number B and it's X weighs maybe
we need to figure out the measurements I
hope I mean I don't know cuz that was
math yeah and that doesn't correspond
with anything I have here like I've got
nothing compared to you well you've got
yeah true oh you've got who's them
you've got letters but you don't have
numbers right yeah well I have a status
but I just feel like it should it should
be something because we always have
something in the corresponding rooms you
know what I mean
so always traveling together yeah I
guess
wait so Milanovic said is the clock
related to the compasses from the first
puzzle you solved that's what I was
thinking
what was the hands where were the hands
again
so North and South East and mine were
both northeast so it's two different
times
mine was on like a that was like a
smaller circle and a bigger circle both
in the same one so it looks more like a
clock so it looked like it was you know
well it's my my both on the outsides
that gone yes my looks more like a clock
and they're both northeast it's like
five past one right Jackson this game is
five pounds and so you get copies free
pad says well only I don't know if you
do now actually that was like a yeah it
might might still be running so check it
out yeah but yeah very pop says I can't
play this game because I'm dumb I'm sure
you're not and you have no friends and I
can't
you must have one friend I mean yeah
you've got somebody very much okay feel
like I can't play this game anymore
I'm just so difficult as the things
you've telling me that you can see it
I've got this one thing I know I'm gonna
like ICC got five sheets of paper
telling me like random crap that you
apparently don't even need so just
frustrating can't see how Roswell thinks
this 12:15 for some reason like so now
you keep saying northeast which I guess
we should do because that would be eased
huh you don't have north 12:15 would be
north and east not northeast yeah it's
like five past one o'clock terms with
not five pasty there is it like it's not
even it's it's like in the tree it's
like what is seven past
something like not possible with how
many seconds oh we killed by any scales
this room I'm the zoom ahead I'm gonna
go explore as you well see to figure out
right there must be something
yeah I've just got all those dials and
the post office you've got nothing that
can help me with that because this has
numbers like do you see any like 44 wait
what did you say 44 44 I've got I've got
all these like 2.4 pretty much an 18
long words like all the even numbers
I've got up into 48 in boxes that I
can't open so that's fun yeah I don't
worry about that cuz I remember when I
had that seen I could only open like one
as well maybe hmm maybe you asked my
keys the apparatus on the desk no I
can't
I've been clicking it so basically I've
got this like thing but I think oh why
person call into the box the name is the
barrage I didn't realize it was spelt
like that yeah okay who said that
yes yeah Dustin yeah I guess it's
probably tipsy way of lost where the
bird is I'm sorry I don't have a
registry it's K they're asking for my
live stream oh what's that they can see
your screen screen oh yeah that would be
a good idea yeah sorry I'm an amateur
Oh
yes what are you doing waiting for you
sorry I have to cook okay something's
happening okay girl yes yes Dustin ok
the breads awake and it's just looking
around
ok I clicked it and it coordinates I I
lit up and now I won't shut up I wish I
didn't click it oh my god stop can you
click on the Browse and do anything with
the bread it's just pointing at me it
won't shut up ok wait is it doing short
cause and then long cause the Morse code
yes
oh yeah right okay it stopped clicking
it so it's it shut up now so I'll do let
it core this down it does Excel
forgetting I'm going well I'm at the
Morse code place now anyway okay right
so short one long one okay short one
long one uh-huh wait I'll just write it
down because it's doing it fast
okay right so did dot dash dot dash dash
dash dot dot dash dash dash dot no
that's too many that's too much that's
too much how much do you need want to
move even ten they'll give me twelve let
me just click it going let's see
Dustin's so happy now he's like I'm
smart you're scared you are smart Dustin
thank you
it just did the same thing it is hmm
let's just try again
so did it not work okay so so doc - yeah
doc - - - wait I messed up one sec okay
right dot dash dot dash dash dash okay
I'm running out of space already
yeah doc dot dr. - - - - and now I've
run out of space in myself
okay let me take it this has gotta be it
though right yeah
hmm I just did the same thing
Jackson's come over and he's actin all
smug cuz he's good at these games I've
no idea what you doing okay math code
Morse code oh wait okay it's AI lights
up on some of them ah there you go
oh wait but just the dashes that doesn't
make sense
maybe just do all dashes what okay I
don't know
wait how many caches are there seven one
two three four five six seven
I've gotta do 10 I've gotta do 10
so I just need to again
Vicki said maybe Colin Moss
maybe just mmm it would just make more
sense that what the bird is doing would
correlate to the right Morse code I just
searched Cole Morse code and I got
obnoxious riddle solution the Cole wiki
excuse me what is this
the obnoxious file for the item
obnoxious dog gif actually contains an
embedded mp3 the gift can be opened
directly in many mp3 players what is
this what is Cole what if we are just
link covered I think we've just been
covered a conspiracy theory you should
tell Shane listen to the mp3 file for
what sounds like Morse code if he can
transcribe it directly you're amazing
it's easier to open what the [ __ ] is
this
where's this referring to you kingdom of
loathing it's a kingdom of loathing
Ricky I don't know what kingdom of
loathing is and now I'm so confused and
I feel like this game was referencing
something we've went down the rabbit
hole where are we twitch Morse code Cole
what Cole secrets remained hidden for
the longest time what is this I don't
know if this boat is doing my head a
kingdom of loathing a redditor is you
the sunken chest is still unsolved
although I'm in the Jake is mocking us
camp No this is so weird this is by the
way coincidental or they're definitely
referencing the kingdom of loathing or
whatever the hell this is anyway wait
look at this chat I can't see it were
they saying
they've got K is I don't take a - oh
wait not - - - oh this looks like it
could be right - no I got so excited
nothing happened [ __ ] bird because
it's it's it's like attached to a light
bulb that I can't turn on oh maybe you
should just do it without the first
starting - cuz then that takes away -
and then it works the one that I gave
you okay so it's dot dash dash dash dot
dot dash dash dash stop
I'm gonna try Carl again no I need to
sneeze
yeah or leaves the dock at the beginning
at the end I was just gonna say that
okay
okay so what is it without those dots
then so it's um dash dot dash dash dash
dot dot dot dot dash dash dash
I'm just gonna try someone on the Rick
zuman and so but his name is so much
like we need a nickname fees
zom zom zom Oh sounds like an alien
thing can't click the numbers
Jackson's chatter hmm yeah we've already
read postbox 34 if Jackson confuses well
now yeah he tried to help me that he
wasn't any help he's like no I'm done
he's in the kitchen now making it a nice
Oh get boyfriend yeah I wanna chef he's
best chef I have to do everything on my
life life is hard
I'll cook singer okay please so I still
be edible but I'll cook it right let me
listen to it again
I mean that's the only thing I can think
of I can't think of anything else yeah
stupid space invaders on the hell yes
[Music]
I'm sorry she's reading the chat um a
drinky something fun it's vegan ale
my housemate bought it for me okay
yeah she was like oh we got a bit of
extra bills this month here's a cheating
Oh Jackson is literally got a pen and
hey okay hmm I think he thinks I'm
writing it down wrong no thumbs like
maybe the birth of a whole turn this ham
yeah so it's 12 we're getting dots and
dashes we need 10 10 dots and dashes
we don't need letters yeah yeah it's not
about the letters it's not otherwise you
should've been watching your live stream
[Music]
I wonder how many bulbs that are outside
that we need to figure out later
oh there's 24 guys I don't know if you
knew this but alcohol a lot of the time
gets saved through fish butter which is
why it's not vegan or vegetarian because
they're like what there's a meeting I
don't understand
makes any do the alcohol all well it's
because it's still it's still going
through them no I understand the whole
vegan oh I just don't understand why
they did that in the first place
oh yeah I don't know maybe like cheaper
perhaps don't name oh I don't know
either
it just seems gross mm-hmm yeah I know
when I found out I was like why
goodnight babe have fat
my fish blood gelatine yeah most wines
aren't vegan true but wines gross so
that's fine wines not too bad I mean my
mom drinks all the time I really don't
like wine I can't drink it because it I
just I just get super sleepy or like
very drunk very fast but you're just not
a fun type of drunk though it's like
yeah it's like that time it's like
headachy sleepy yeah I haven't drank
that much of it to get why I'm drunk too
gross but my mom would just give me wine
all the time I thought like maybe if I
turned off my lights outside that
because I've got a light that's attached
to the the thing but it's not turned on
I was like maybe I'm just sucking the
power but oh wait I think it's gonna
turn on when I get it right wait someone
said read postbox 34 again maybe it's in
the message because she says short
sometimes I think we'd write and long oh
wait she says okay right it feels like I
was gone for such a long time so that
would be a - right for all the time I
was away it still felt short too short
to finish my invention too short okay
oh okay so that would be - a lot - wait
wait no you said say that again
okay so - don't stop no no - see the
letter again oh it feels like I was gone
for such a long time
okay sit long yeah but for all the time
I was away it still felt short
okay that's wonder yeah too short okay
two dots to finish my invention now we
will have the longest lives ever
okay longer than you could imagine when
you've repeated this message I'll guide
your weight do it twice so you need to
if do you have it yes wait wait
so do dash dot dot dash dash I'm gonna
do that twice
wait dash dash dot dot yeah - - and then
do dash dot dot dash - oh my god it
works thank you it's someone in the chat
told me thank you
the real Baja Co how do you say that
back her name but thank you it's just a
creepy lips in the corner of every
thanks I just the technician and a chef
and every time I see guys chef IT guy
[Laughter]
okay I have like a random like a light
okay
it does what it's just making the light
bowl go Jimmy go well go on and off
because of the Morse code it's just
doing the Moscow basically but I don't
really know how that's gonna help me is
there anything else
she go outside see if there's anything
changed said she would help us
no it's still creepy outside how are you
says now try the birdie code can you do
that when you leave this message I'll
guide your way yeah guided us I just
don't really get how anything would
change in urine now because we're not
playing on the same service so your game
doesn't know that I've done this yes -
tell me what you see you just see a
light bulb going on and off yes the bulb
it lights up completely on the - and the
the innards of it so like the spirals a
bit go a light on a dots and both of
those things bulb gets lit up on a - and
the like spirally bit gets lit up on a
dark there's a spiral a bit is it giving
you like juice on those no nothing
nothing no words no yeah no letters no
numbers it's just the light bulb going
on and off and either the whole light
bulb goes on or just hoards just the
coil inside the light bulb okay so
they're telling us that it could be the
light bulbs outside but this doc - doc
doc doc - okay there was a pause there
as well
wait let me let me do this again all
right get ready to write this down okay
wait am i writing this time i gue yeah
you because I don't have a pen oh sorry
I just used my phone but it's fine I've
got a pen with my phone okay right well
I'm writing down
okay so darts - yeah dots dots paws dots
- yeah paws - - yep
pause dots - - put dot sorry
there was no pause they don't stop so is
that it just repeats bar it just did
that once and then it ended so I reckon
that yeah that might be outside and the
pauses are way apps way but we can only
turn them on or off yes you've maybe -
on for a - and one on three dot oh yeah
okay let's try that and then obviously
the pause is like we'd skip it okay
where do we stop I reckon it's probably
clockwise going from the the Casper the
station baby wait the stage what do you
think clockwise starting from the
station cuz it looks like a the gates
not like a clock right and it's like
it's going from 12 yeah but do we start
on the right-hand side because that's
because you had those gates there's like
two halves to it yeah yeah yeah like
clockwise yeah okay so it's dark - does
that mean we leave all three on yeah
okay yeah and then we moved to next one
next one with the house yeah and then
it's dark and then it stops
dun duh and then keep one off yes I
guess and then so then that's the gap
and then it stopped - so we leave all of
those it doesn't make any sense
I know we're just trying okay um and
then it's - - and then there's a gap -
and then gap right yeah and then don't
know I don't think that like and then -
- stop with so gaps wait wait wait we
have another one - - . what - - stop did
you see - - that I did okay so I'm back
at the place and there's nothing - stop
with a pause
[Music]
I was looking at your Facebook when you
were streaming the other day and you put
the hashtags for ticket op game in it
and it's funny
Thanks
not that ticked up people I think oh
yeah yeah it's good I forgot to update
restream because you have to update
YouTube twitch and everything but no too
many things too many things yeah cuz I
was telling my friend Adam he was like
wise jazz playing takes hours like now
she's having me it's got to be something
to do with gates that's all we've got
left right unless we try the bad stuff
on it so we know what it is let's go
upstairs in the house Ashley the city
bless you Jackson are you gonna see you
go say thank you he did these birds code
for one side and the bulbs for the other
yeah so actually that would make sense
so on my on my my thingy like I say I
have the clock that's obviously going
anti-clockwise and it's gots it looks
like kind of what we see on the gates
and then I think I said you know I said
inside of it it's got the metronome
thing it's not mentioning sorry the EM
you know those codes
yeah Morse code thing on the left and
then it's got your bird head on the
right so perhaps there is a mixture of
the two and you do the birds head stuff
and I do what my
says but we're not together but I start
from six to twelve so that'll be from
the bottom of the map to the top so from
whatever is opposite the train station
back to the train station and then you
go from the train station I think it's
the trumpet shoppers opposite I think
but how do we do dashes because I feel
like they would all just be lit up yeah
[Music]
yeah yeah girls code has 12 dashes dots
but there are 24 none so great
yeah because some have dots or off
dashes are on another destined one yeah
well that's what Dustin says in the chat
he was right about the the other thing
I'll have to start because we both have
to go clockwise so I'll have to start
opposite the gates and do it from there
and then you've got both of our things
written down you've still got the
bedroom right yeah wait why don't we
just do it together cuz I love to do it
anyway
oh I see yeah yeah cool we'll just sure
we start with the that the gate yeah
do I have to start with the burnt stuff
yeah okay and we're starting on the
right-hand side of the gate like those
lights okay yeah okay so the bird code
was dot - so if you turn a light off for
a dot and leave - on for a - or just one
on how many have you got because we've
got one sorry
yeah but if we're starting with the
three on the right we've got three tell
me what you mean like many got some - it
yeah because we've got 12 lights overall
so do we have 12 dozen we do have 12
dots and dashes because there were too
many weren't there
yeah hey okay great yeah so let's do
that
don't go right oh and dashes on okay so
dot dash dot so off on off okay and then
the next one is - - - that means three
are all on
yeah the next one is - the - off one on
okay and then dash dash dot so - on on
off cool and now my one other code so
that's dot dash dot so off on off yeah
then dot dot dash oh yeah then dash dash
dot okay yeah
and now then again - - stop it works
does yours work yeah yeah tower okay
what do you see hey Tom I talked about
you last night
it's not as weird as it sounds I promise
you here's the horror it was a nightmare
I mean I know I know it I've even about
Tom and I haven't I met Thomas username
zero oh hi yeah this is dandy night Oh
have fun with that what did you see
thanks upwards a lantern yep and looks
like I can get up wait
yeah ladders coming down oh oh I can't
have some words me too okay so I'll
start because I'm guessing I stuff that
mines in the beginning all those years
in Switzerland made it possible for me
to finally finish the clock work my last
memory of luck was
suspicion from all suspicious frown on
her face wait won't say that again my
last memory of I don't know how to say
that name logic work on her face I
thought he was a man was the suspicious
frown on her face one should go all this
time I thought she was a man okay yeah
I'm going up okay there's another ladder
yeah more words yep i double-checked
Alaric's clock it ran exactly as it
should
at first she didn't want the clock she
said she was tired of my present tired
oh the the bread that wouldn't die she's
tired of it finishing with the clock she
said I don't know she was tired of my
present yeah yeah but like presents
acidic you Oh presents oh yeah yeah
presents oh but Welsh she got made that
present right that the bird that
wouldn't die
that was the present wasn't it well they
yeah but they're talking about the clock
so they're not talking about the bird
just yeah I think so we go off again
yeah it didn't occur to me that a crack
and the clock face would make a
difference I held it out to her anyways
because I needed her to be with me oh oh
now I have jars do you see them yeah
that's like fireflies oh no I don't have
fireflies of mine right that mine are
all dead Oh what numbers have you got
one zero one one
yeah me too one three zero eight same
one one one one yeah and then when I
I had spent years collecting time for us
time that would be added to our lives
are so this must be the time and the
jars right I never told her that the
time was stolen only that the clock
would let us be together forever
wait zero just said Oh Tom just said oh
it's lark as if he knows who is lark
what I don't know how to say that I've
kind of stairs with like more jars
oh yeah it's like loads instead she
disappeared into the clock and I still
haven't found her she closed her hand
around the clock and I never see again
she's like oh I'm in sight I'm hot yes
there is a jar with no number oh I just
and there's like a soul going inside is
it mine one seven eight nine one nine
eight oh okay I didn't have to build a
way out I hope you and your friend
appreciate it
you beat the game such a shame to steal
that phone go to waste
what sorry we beat the game you have
lost 178 minutes of your life oh I've
lost one nine eight minutes he must have
left the game on in the background or
something after we fished i love that i
am i all Woozles having fun leave me
alone games stop telling me how to spend
my time Emily I did 178 minutes to hers
it said located one nine eight to her it
is that's interesting that's quite cool
narrative mmm yeah definitely is yeah
and I really like the idea of it being
co-op I just like yeah really wish that
this was running on the same server so
whenever I did something yeah like
you're that part where you had the bells
it would be so cool if you just rang one
of them and I could actually hear it and
I was like oh I'm gonna hear you like no
yeah so cool it's like in the distant
far-off circle well it's just like
knowing that your gameplay is actually
affecting mine yes but they were good in
you that time well well I think that you
solved the puzzle and I thought that you
couldn't go back and I was like alright
this is so bad at least they thought
around that and they were like okay
let's make it even if someone does get
past the puzzle they can still go back
and do it again to help out the other
one but yeah yeah I saw I'd ruined
everything that I was quite what's that
yeah me too like this girl she's not a
team player
I help friendship okay okay no no I get
it I guess we need to find another game
to play now I know Emily's yeah I need
to make the art for it though yeah some
said time you enjoy wasting is not
wasted time that's very true times we
get to hang out you yeah the friends my
mom the other day and I was like I don't
really like we don't really speak that
often even though you're my best friend
but I just don't speak to you that all
that often but this is a good chance to
spend some time anything different
together yeah I guess we don't really
message like text people like we'd
rather talk on the phone or something
says too much to type yeah
you couldn't a full of the things and
we're both not massive talkers anyway
not no not really no like in the sense
that you know we don't want to come home
from work and then just spend an hour on
the phone rather come home from where I
can like what you do yeah just not talk
for a bit yeah because my job I talk
updates I don't want to talk anymore
yeah yeah I mean I don't I don't do that
but I thought I was gonna get no we was
just like mentally draining I go yeah
well yeah that was fun we're gonna have
to find another game to play definitely
because I think plan to do this next
week with you we're gonna have to find a
new game from it any suggestions anyone
yeah if anyone knows any kids
multiplayer games I'm just wondering
because you obviously you're used to
playing with the controller but you can
always just like plug the Xbox
controller into the PC anyway so we can
play I used to be a massive like
computer game like not like massive
games but I used to play a lot of
computer games when I was in my teens
okay cuz I was gonna say we could get we
could get like oh my god well it's that
cooking game that you and Jackson
playing I figure it's a cold what's the
cooking game that we've got oh it's not
this makes me wait I'll go grab it
you guys will all know
overcooked that's the one Oh Mario
America oh yeah we need to America but
that's on switch so we can't stream them
I don't know else we pass today the
Beast I don't know you know Paul about
game console I do
I don't think so actually cuz I would
need to stream it from my switch into
the PC into the stream and yeah it would
be super bad okay so we need to find
things
they don't deem yeah hey one of my
friends is not playing tik-tok a tail a
tail for - hey what am I seeing
runs I just saw her come up it's like
yes I will say this game is cool play
with someone yeah we'll find a good game
anyway if it's not over Kirk's it will
be some other weird game it was like
answering board lines I I don't know we
I mean we could play probably your
anthem but like apex but I don't know if
you would enjoy it I'm really bad as
shoot yeah finish your games and I think
it's better off just playing like a
puzzle game or like something yes thank
you
weird like this yeah something cute
weird and I'm up for that because it's
cool to play play different games yeah I
like a little indie games as well I like
yeah I love indie games you always show
me the cool like the ones we got
obsessed with music oh my gosh yes when
when you were in the shower and wait who
has a story going when you're in the
shower and I found plants vs. zombies on
the Capcom web player whatever it was
and you came back you're like what is
this game PopCap yeah and you're like
wow this game was like oh you just
played clean simply so you killed some
dandies and then we just spent the whole
day playing him and that's that's before
it got popular
yeah if we were we were hipsters we've
played it before anyone else played it
it was so stupid I like to just remember
you coming back at me like you put this
plant there and not plant there okay
I was just yelling at the laptop
pointing and you were just clicking away
like quick yeah and I was like Tommy's
coming oh okay no oh yes you can oh wait
I don't like it okay wait I'm taking
young you just look pretty bored oh
really oh yeah it's like lag so you're
probably seeing me in the past due to me
now but you'll see me you heard that's
weird
Wow yeah I'm very behind wait whoa you
shouldn't be watching that unless you
had it pause do you mind
I had it pause I went on it by Joffrey
thanks for coming yep I golf it uh-oh
wait I think Tom just said he messaged
me a game suggestion on Facebook oh I
used like swaying from left to right oh
it's up yeah I kind of need the toilet
oh yeah you are lucky yeah yeah it
always is
that's the way it goes facebook facebook
facebook
we were here ooh oh this sounds cool oh
my god thank you Tom okay so we've got a
cool game to play so Tom just sent me
this game called we were here and Nitz
you're lost in a frozen wasteland and
split up from your partner in sudden
abandon Castle the only possession you
have is a walkie-talkie with a familiar
voice on the other end can the two of
you find your way out in time it sounds
like we could get like visit time' they
should be fun um let's read more about
the game this game requires both players
to have a working pc so we'll need to be
on PC again but that should be ok
[Music]
it's a standalone puzzle adventure ok so
player 1 is confined to a small secluded
part of the castle and player 2 roams
the halls trying to find player 1 every
room challenges your wits and ability to
communicate clearly using only your
voice oh my god
I've run out of wits I'm screwed it's an
Eric thriller that'll keep you on the
edge of your seats so you're gonna be
scared and you're gonna pee a lot maybe
you always feel like cool it's my
amnesia so yeah it is kind of scary
should be good Chuck since Chuck is
asking us if he played that game the way
you disarm the bomb have you seen that
one oh yeah yeah I have seen that one
that's another game we can play cuz
apparently this one's pretty short too
so maybe we can just like work our way
through a bunch of yeah random oh you
player ones I think game for that just a
bit different
no mercy is like can you say ooh whoo
what is that I thought it was a face
it's a face no cause people say it
gently but I don't know what it means
what hmm
Google's a thing let me google it
do you ever think good good cool hmm
wait with OHS we'll use it's a meme and
Mosin mom
yeah it's a it's a little face I'll see
I knew this oh why does he say can you
say it then maybe because maybe there
are people like a music okay I think I
was trying to catch you out what is the
meaning what is the meeting of you with
what is the meaning yes it's the face
okay I need to go to the toilet see
something yeah okay thanks for watching
guys
yeah this is fun join us next week I'll
probably have to do Saturday cuz I've
got I've got an interview on Sunday in
Brighton I'm working this weekend wait I
thought you said what I work every other
weekend so it's all Flast weekend I'm
working
Oh so why are we planning on dating that
weekend after maybe I don't know we
haven't really discussed it
okay well about after this tree and then
I'll let you guys know yeah it's good
okay have a lovely day or evening bye
[Music]